اليوم تسليمه اوكرانيا دبابات لو بارد
وزلميسكي يطالبوا الغربه بقرارات سريعه
مناوراتنا امريكيه اسرائيليه ضخمه تنطلق
اليوم لمحاكاه قصف اهداف النوويه ايرانيه
تشارك فيها طائرات بي 52
متوقعه بين حكومه الوحده الوطنيه وايطاليا
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل الخير واهلا بكم الى
فتره اخباريه جديده من العربيه البدايه
بهذه النشره في الوقت الذي يعتزم فيه
المستشار الالماني
اليوم عن السماحي في ارسال دبابات لو بارت
2 الى اوكرانيا وجه رئيس لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه بمجلس النواب الامريكي مايكل
ماكول انتقادته للحكومه الامريكيه على
تاخرها القرار وقلم قال انه لا يوجد عذر
امام المانيا لهذا التاخير الذي دام شهورا
وتسبب في سقوط ارواح الاوكرانيين واطاله
الحرب غير المبرره ولفت مقال الى ان
المبادره وتولي زمام المبادره في دعم
اوكرانيا داخل اوروبا يجب ان تتخذه
الحكومه الالمانيه بدل وضع شروط على
الولايات المتحده لنقل دبابات ابرامز
وكانت الانباء الالمانيه قالت ان المستشار
الالماني والشرطي سيعلن اليوم ارسال
دبابات لو بارد الى اوكرانيا كما انه منح
الاذن باعاده تصدير دبابات لوبرد
لاوكرانيا من قبل الدول الاوروبيه كولندا
بدورها قال صحيفه طولستروزورنال ان ان
امريكا والمانيا
سترسلني عددا قليلا من الدبابات في اطار
صفقه في وقت اكدت مصادر امريكيه ان
الاعلان الامريكي قد يكون الاربعاء ايضا
فيما كشفت صحيفه تدرس بدل الالمانيه ان
المانيا سترسل 10 دبابات لو بارد له
اوكرانيا ولكنها موعد الوصول غير محدد
بدله كبيره اذا احدثتها دبابات ليوبارتوال
المانيه هل تعطيها المانيا ام لا وهل تسمح
لاخرين بتصيلها هذا الاسرار الاوكراني
اولا والغربي ثانيا على تزويد اكياس بهذه
الدبابات اسبابه متعدده لكن اهم هذه
الاسباب ان لا يعتبر ستشكل نقل نوعيه في
الحرب مع منحها القوات الاوكرانيه القدره
الهجوميه وليس فقط الدفاع وصد الهجمات
الروسيه فضلا عن السهوله اللوجستيه
المانيا انت جد نحو تسعه الاف قطعه من هذه
الدبابات منذ عام
1963 ويتم تصنيع النوع نفسه في ثلاث دول
اخرى بترخيص من المانيا وتستخدمها جيوش
احدى 20 دوله
تشير التقديرات مشاهدينا الحاليه الى وجود
نحو الفايد الدبابات تو في اوروبا اكثر من
423 دبابه منها مخزنه في الم وفقا للمعهد
الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه تركيا تملك
316 دبابه لوبان تليها بولندا مع 200
ودببتين واليونان مع 183 دبابات اما
سويسرا فتمتلك همم من دبابات اليابان
1434 او 30 دبابات وفيما لا يزال الاخد
والرد متواصلا ابدا شركه المعدات العسكريه
همم
الالمانيه استعدادها لتزويد اوكرانيا
بمائه وتسعه وثلاثين دبابه من طراز ليبارا
اذا لازمه الامر اضافات انه يمكن للشركه
تسليم 99 دبابه بحلول اي برو او مايو همم
واثنتين و20 دبابه اخرى بحلول نهايه العام
الحالي كما اكدت مشاهدينا الشركه
الالمانيه امكانيه ارسال
معنى انه 80 دبابه من طراز ليوبار 1 دون
تحديد الموعد حتى الساعه
الرئيس الاوكرانيه طلب الدول الغربيه
باتخاد قرارات سريعه لتسليم بلاده دفعه
جديده من الدبابه الحديثه والمتطوره
عن الدبابات الحديثه التي نحتاجها هناك
الكثير من الجهود والوعود ولكن يجب الا
تغيب عن بالنا الوقائع فالامر لا يتعلق
بخمس او عشر او خمس عشره دبابه فقط الحاجه
اكبر من ذلك بكثير نحن نفعل يوميا كل ما
هو ضروري لسل هذا النقص في الدبابات واشكر
كل من يدعمنا في هذا الشان لكن المناقشات
يجب ان تؤدي الى قرارات بشان التعزيز
الحقيقي لمواجهه الارهابيين لدى حلفائنا
العدد المطلوب من الدبابات وعندما يتوصلون
الى القرار المناسب عندها يسعدنا ان
نشكرهم على ذلك
كما اشارت النسكي الى ان روسيا تحصد قوتها
وتكثف من عملتها الهجوميه من اجل سيطره
على مدينه بخموت دعيا العالم الى مساندته
من اجل مواجهه ما وصفه بالجرائم الروسيه
الجديده
وهي تستمر بزياده ضغطها على مخموط وبلدان
ومواقع اخرى
المسؤولون الروسي يريدون تجنب الاخطاء
السابقه ولذلك سيحشدون في هجومهم غالبيه
رجالهم وعتادهم بالتالي يتعين علينا جميعا
في العالم الحر ان نعزز تعاوننا من اجل
مواجهه الجرائم الروسيه الجديده
في المقابل وصف سفير روسيا لدى الولايات
المتحده انطوني انطونوب عمليه تسنيم
دبابات قتاليه محتمله من قبل واشنطن
اوكرانيا
بالاستفزاز الصارخ الجديد لروسيا وقال انت
نوفا في تصريحات نشرت على تطبيق تيليجرام
ان واشنطن وبكل وضوح تحاول عن قصد الحاق
هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا واضاف ان تنوف
بانه اذا قررت الولايات المتحده تزويده
اوكرانيا بالدبابات فان تبريره مثل هذه
الخطوه بالحجاج حول الاسلحه الدفاعيه لن
ينجح بالتاكيد
[تصفيق]
افاده مراسل العربيه بان تدريب المشتركه
بين القوات الجويه الاسرائيليه والقياده
المركزيه الامريكيه سيقصف اهداف تحاكم
واقعناويه ايرانيه اليوم الاربعاء وحسب
تقرير لتلفزيون الاسرائيلي فان قاذفات
امريكيه ستلقي مئه طن من المتفجرات على
اهداف في صحراء النقب بجنوب اسرائيل في
اطار التمرينات
اكدت نائبه وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ويندي
شيرمان في خطاب بولايه كليبلاند ان العوده
الى الاتفاق النوويه الايراني لا تسال
ممكنه وقالت شيرمان ان خطط العمل الشامله
المشتركه المعروفه باسم الاتفاق النووي لا
تزال احد الخيارات الممكنه لكنها ليست
الان على جدول الاعمال
تتراجعوا الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في ايران
بشكل تدريجي بسبب الاساليب القمعيه التي
يستخدمها النظام الايراني
لمواجهه الغضب الشعبي وبعد مرور 4 اشهر من
الاحتجاجات وتنام الشعبي بشكل غير مسبوق
تلا شازخ متظاهرات لكن الغضب في اعلى
مستوياته الاحكام القاسيه التي كانت موجهه
ضد المنشقين والاقليات العرقيه والنساء
على وجه التحديد
جعلت بقيه المتظاهرين الايرانيين يخشون من
مواجهه نفس المصير
سلسله الاعدامات لم تكن السبب الوحيد في
تلاش هذه الاحتياجات الشعبيه
بالرصاص والاعتقالات الجماعيه والاعتداء
الجسدي والعنف الجنسي
كلها عوامل اساسيه كان لها دور في انخفاض
المعارضه من الشارع الايراني من جهه
وازدياد الاستياء الشعبيه العام من جهه
اخرى
وتحديدا في المناطق الحدوديه التي تهيمن
عليها الاقليات والتي تحملت العب الاكبر
من قمع النظام
وكما يرى مراقبون فان معظم الاشخاص الذين
تزيد اعمارهم عن 25 عاما ابتعدوا عن
المظاهرات
بالاضافه الى الجيل الاكبر سنا منهم
والذين ضلوا الى حد كبير بعيدا عن الشوارع
التي تعمها الاحتجاجات وهو الامر الذي حرم
الحركه الاحتجاجيه الزخم اللازمه لاسقاط
النظام الايراني
بان تعود هذه الانتفاضه مجددا ضد النظام
الايراني بسبب عدم قدرته على معالجه
المشاكل الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه بسبب
العقوبات الدوليه المطلوبه عليها
سلطان العيبان العربيه
ونبقى معكم في سياق هذه النشره ولدينا
معرض في مارب يسلط الضوء على انتهاكات
ميليشيا الحوثي بعنوان شتاء صنعاء
نواصل مع حضراتكم تقديم هذه النشره في
ليبيا قالت حكومه فتحي باشا المكلفه من
البرلمان ان عزم رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا
جورجيا حضوره توقيعتفاق النفطي الجديد مع
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه برئاسه عبد الحميد
بيبا هو سلوك انت هذه يغمر بالعلاقه بين
البلدين واعلنت حكومه بشار في بيانها ان
حكومه منتهيه الولايه ولم تتمتع باهليه
توقيع اي اتفاقيات او مذكراتهم واشار بيان
الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه الى الاعداد
للصفقها بانها غامضه بين المؤسسه الوطنيه
التي قال انها تقضي بزياده حصه الشريك
الاجنبي وتقلي سحب الشركه الوطنيه
في تونس اكادت النقابه النقل تابعه
للاتحاد التونسي للشغل ان موعد اضراب
القطاع برا وبحرا وجوا سيتاجل الى يومي
الخامس عشر و16 من مارس المقبل وفقا لما
ذكره مسؤول النقابي المصدر ذاته قال في
تصريح ان الاعلام المحلي ان الاضراب
قائمون في ظل تواصل تجاهل الحكومه لمطالب
القطاع واقرارها مرسوما لخصصه المؤسسات
العموميه على حد تعبيرها
في العراق كشفت قياده عمليات بغداد عن خطط
المتكامله لتامين الحمايه للمتظاهرين خلال
التظاهر المرتقبه اليوم قرب البنك المركزي
احتجاجا على ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار مقابل
الدينار وقال قائد عمليات بغداد الفريق
الركنه احمد سليم ان القياده والزعت الفرق
الامنيه المتمثله بوحداث حفظ القانون
لتوفير الحمايه للمتظاهرين واكدا انه لا
قطع لاي طريق في بغداد الا في حال الضروره
اكد محامي مايك فانس نائب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق ترامب العثور على وثائق سريه في
منزل بنسب ولايه انديانا الاسبوع الماضي
وتم احالتها الى مكتب التحقيقات الاتحاديه
العثور على وثائق مصنفه سريه في منازل
الرسائل الامريكيين ونوابهم يدل على ان
المشكله تكمن في ترقيم هذه الوثائق
والتاكد من من يحتفظ بها وكيفيه استرجاعها
تقرير الزميل من واشنطن
تبدو قضيه الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها
الرئيس الحالي جو فايدن والرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب مؤشرا على مشكله حقيقيه
تواجهها اجهزه الدوله الامريكيه مع
الرؤساء الامريكيين
السيناتور الديمقراطيه
كشفها كيف يتم التعامل مع الوثائق المصنفه
السريه
وانا اقرا ثم يستعيدها ويضعها في الحقيبه
ويغادر
لكن المساله مختلفه مع الرئيس الامريكي من
الممكن ان نرى الرئيس سبايدر وهو يغادر
وبيده اوراق ويذهب الى مقر الاقامه في
المبنى الرئيسي من البيت الابيض او الى
الطائره لا احد يتابع مع الرئيس الامريكي
ما حصل للاوراق المصنفه سريه
ومرقمه ولا احد يسال عنها او يطلب
استعادتها من الرئيس عندما يغادر او عندما
ينتهي من استعمالها هذه واحده من المشاكل
لكن ما حصل مع بيضه ومن قبله ترامب يتراوح
بين الاهمال والاصرار على عدم احترام
الاجراءات الامنيه وحمايه الوثائق السريه
فبعض الوثائق موجود بحوزه بايضا منذ كان
عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي وقبل ان يصبح
نائبا للرئيس العام 2009
نظام المكتبات العامه وعندما يعطى الرئيس
وثيقه وهي عاده تاتي من السي اي اي او
وزاره الدفاع يجب ان تكون مسجله ومرقمه
الحل الاخر المطروح هو تحويل كل الوثائق
السريه الى النظام الالكتروني وبالتالي
يقفل الدخول اليها بمجرد انتهاء الرئيس من
استعمالها وهذا ما حصل في الاجاز الامني
للرئيس في المكتب البيضاوي في الغانم
العربيه
كانوا معتقلين في مخيمات يحتجز فيها عناصر
متطرفه تابعه لداعش شمال شرق سوريا وفق
وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه وافدت الوزاره في
بيان انه تم تسليم القاصرين الى الهند الى
الاجهزه المكلفه بالمساعده الاطفال وستقدم
لهم متابعه طبيه اجتماعيا
الفرنسيه هنا عملوا على ترتيبات نقل 32
طفلا وخمسه عشره امراه من عائلات
الفرنسيين لداعش والمحتجزين في مخيمات شرق
سوريا جاء ذلك بعد ان قررت باريس التخلي
عن سياستها في دراسته لحاله جرى انتقادات
من عائلات عناصر داعش الفرنسيه والامم
المتحده هذه الخطوه تاتي بعد ثلاثه ايام
من ايام لجنه ملاحظه التعذيب في الامم
المتحده لفرنسي بالتقصير في حمايتها هؤلاء
النساء والاطفال ورغ فعي باريس عن موقفها
السابق الرافض لعودتهم بشكل جماعي تحت
مبرر ان معاهده مناهضه التعذيب لا تفرض
على اي بلد حمايه مواطني في اراد ليست تحت
سلطته القضائيه الا انها رضى خط وقبيله
استقبالهم من باريس زينه عادي
افتتح في محافظه مارب اليمنيه معرض مفتوح
لصور الفوتوغرافيه حمل عنوان شتاء صنعاء
وشامله الصور التي علقت على جدران احد
الشوارع الرئيسيه في مارب الوضع الانساني
والحقوقي في العاصمه الخاضعه لسيطره
الميليشيا الحوثيه وانتهاكاتها بحق
اليمنيين
هكذا تحولت العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء خلال
ثمان سنوات من سيطره الميليشيات الحوثيه
عليها
انتهاكات وازمات ومشاهد ومعرفها اليمنيون
من قبل في جداريه مارب المفتوحه صورا تمثل
شهادات على تلك الجرائم وكشفا لما يحصل في
صنعاء
الاطفال
تغيير المناهج طالت الاموال العامه ونهضه
الاموال همم انتهاكات طارت الصحافه
والصحافيين المراه اليمنيه لم تكتفي
الميليشيات الحوثيه باهانتها في طوابير
البحث عن الماء والغاز بل جنه ذاتها في
تشكيلات مسلحه تابعه لها اطلقت عليها
الزينبيات
واسندت اليهن مهام امنيه واستخباراتيه
واقتحام المنازل واعتقالا النساء وتعذيبهم
شواهد لفتاه انظار زوار معرض الصور
المفتوحه هنا في مارب
على المراه سواء من تعذيب سواء من سجن
سواء من همم انتهاكات همم لحقوقها من والى
ليست فقط حقوق حقوق المراه فقط ولكن
حقوقها بشكل عام فهي حقوقها بشكل كبير جدا
الجرائم ولا تسقط وذاكره اليمنيين ليست
مكتوبه حقوقيون لتمثل الصور دليل ادانه
لمحاكمه مرتكبها هذا المعرض يحمل رسالتين
رساله للداخل همم الشعب اليمني الذي
يقبعون تحت في مناطق
امطرت الحوثي وتذكرهم بجرائم وانتهاكات
الحوثي واحياء الذهي الذهنيه للشعب اليمني
بما يرتكبوه مواصله المقاومه الشعبيه
والرفض الشعبي لهذه المليجيات والرساله
الاخرى هي للمجتمع الدولي ومهندسيه تسويات
والمشاورات بان هناك جرائم تركيبات بحق
الشعب اليمني ولا يمكن القفز على حقوق
الضحايا اكثر من 51 الفجريه وانتهاك
وثقتها تقارير حقوقيه ارتكبتها بحق
المدنيين في العاصمه صنعاء خلال العام
الماضي
انتهاكات الميليشيه الحوثيه في العاصمه
صنعاء على هذه الجداريه تبقى شاهده على
حجم المعانات الانسانيه في مناطق سيطره
الانقلاب محمود الحميدي لقناه العربيه
مارب
لفت وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطلب لنكن
الى انه في اليوم العالمي للتعليم يكرم
العالم النساء والفتيات الافغانيات
اللواتي تحرمهن طالبان بشكل منهج من هذا
الحق الانساني واكد بلانك ان العالمي يقف
مع الافغانيات
[موسيقى]
يبدين
من التعليم
اليوم هو اليوم دوري للتعليم والذي تم
تخصيصه لافغانستان ولكن مع الاسف ان ابواب
الجامعات والمدارس مغلقه امام الفتيات
الافغانيات لا لجامعه طالبان لا لمدارس
طالبان لا لحكومه طالبان
ت مع اليوم العالمي للتعليم الذي خصصته
اليونسكو هذا العام لدعم الافغانيات في
حقهن بالتعليم حيث طلب الامين العام للامم
المتحده الحركه بالعدول عن قراراتها التي
منعت اكثر من مليون فتاه من الالتحاق
بالمدارس واكثر من مئه الف طالبه من
ارتياد الجامعه ومنع مئات الالاف منهن من
العمل
امر القامه العديد من الافغانيات بالتظاهر
ضده في عده مناسبات
وفي مواجهه تعنت قيادات طالبان في قندهار
ضاعفه الامم المتحده جهودها لاقناع الحركه
بالتراجع عن قراراتها عبر وفود الامميه
وانسانيه حيث جمدت العديد من المنظمات
الاغاثيه نشاطها في افغانستان بعد قرار
الحركه منع الافغانيه من العمل في هذه
المنظمات
الامر الذي يعرض الملايين من الافغاني
لخطر المجاعه
انا سنماسي العربيه
[موسيقى]
تواجه شركه تويتر دعوه قضائيه من قبل شركه
كراون العقاريه التابعه للعائله الملكيه
البريطانيه بسبب تخلفها عن دفع الايجار
المستحق عن مقر عملها السابق وسط منطقه
بكاتيل في لندن منها العائله الملكيه
تمتلك هذه المنطقه
شركه تويتر تواجه دعوه قضائيه من قبل شركه
كراون العقاريه التابعه للعائله الملكيه
البريطانيه بسبب تخلفها عن دفع الايجار
المستحق لمقر عملها السابق في هذا المبنى
هنا في بيكاديمي في وسط لندن هذه الدعوه
القضائيه ليست الاولى من نوعها يعني طبعا
شركه تويتر تواجه اربع دعاوي على الاقل في
الولايات المتحده حول المشكله ذاتها وهي
دافع ايجار مكاتب تويتر طبعا هذه الدعوه
تاتي بعد انفصل الماسك نصف القوه العامله
للشركه بهذا خفض التكاليف وهو ما دفع
الشركه بالفعل الى همم يعني ترك هذا المقر
همم فهذا المبنى هو واحد من بين المئات من
المباني التي تملكها شركه تكراون العقاريه
وهي اكبر ملاك ل همم الاراضي هنا في
بريطانيا تولد ارباحا للخزينه البريطانيه
يعود حوالي 15% منها الى العائله الملك
على بريطانيا من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربي العربيه
تولى كريس هابتنز رسميا منصب رئيس وزراء
نيوزيلندا خلفا لجاسيون ده ارترين التي
فاجات الجمهور في نيوزيلندا الاسبوع
الماضي باعلن استقالتها وادى هاب كنز
اليمين الدستوريه امام الحاكم العام
نيوزيلندا خلال حفل اقيم في العاصمه قالها
الكنز بعد توله منصبه ان هذا اكبر امتيازا
واكبر مسؤوليه في حياته مضيفا انه يشعر
بالاندفاع والحماسه لمواجهه كل التحديات
الممثله
تفسير بالعربي
بقرارات سريعه
منوره امريكيه اسرائيليه ضخمه تنطلق اليوم
لمحاكاه اهداف النوويه ايرانيه تشارك فيها
طائرات بي 52
متوقعه بين حكومه الوحده الوطنيه وايطاليا
نلتقي على راس على زال لدينا خدمه اخباريه